[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MATTHEW VANDER
HEIDEN: Last time, we
discussed standard reduction
potential, this E0 prime value,
that really is a
way to quantitate
the propensity of a molecule
to accept or donate electrons.
And this is useful to think
about how energy is transduced
in biological systems.
Because remember, as I have
now tried to stress many times,
how energy is moved
through biology
is largely about oxidation
and reduction reactions
involving carbon and
ultimately oxygen.
And so remember that oxidation
of carbon is favorable.
That is removing
electrons from the carbon
and giving them to
oxygen, exactly what we
described for burning
wood or burning gasoline.
And so that's why coming
from the most reduced
carbon like fatty acids
or other reduced carbon
like carbohydrates,
not as reduced
as fatty acids, that oxidizing
that carbon releases energy.
And of course, it means
that storing carbon
as reduced carbon either as
carbohydrates or fatty acids
is a way to store
energy for later.
And so moving from left to
right, equilibrium strongly
favors moving to the right.
That means that delta
G is less than 0
for the oxidation of carbon.
Or we can describe this
as moving from a smaller
standard reduction potential
to a larger standard reduction
potential because, remember, the
relationship between the change
in standard reduction
potential is related
to the equilibrium
constant or delta G0 prime,
which is also related
to the equilibrium
constant by the above formula.
And so we closed last time by
saying that with this formula
we know that, if we move from
a smaller standard reduction
potential-- that is donate
electrons from a smaller
standard reduction potential
to a larger standard reduction
potential-- that that
number, that difference,
will then be positive, which
is the opposite of delta G
because of that formula.
And so a positive change in
standard reduction potential,
moving from lower to
higher, equilibrium
is going to favor
that direction--
should make sense from
everything we discussed before.
And of course, that
change tells you
the propensity of
electron transfer
that ultimately is going to
be favorable at equilibrium.
However, exactly as we
discussed for delta G,
whether an exact
reaction is favorable
is still going to be
dependent on delta G.
And so the change in
standard reduction potential
tells you about the
equilibrium constant,
and so which direction
is going to be
net favorable at equilibrium.
However, what actually
happens is still
going to depend on conditions
for all the reasons
we talked about previously.
Still, this change in
standard reduction potential
is still a useful
concept to think about
because it tells us about
how energy transfer can
occur across redox pairs.
And that will be
useful in thinking
about this process of
oxidative phosphorylation
and how cells really couple
electron transfer to oxygen
as a way to do lots
of useful things
in cells, including making ATP.
Now, one point I want
to come back to again,
which we discussed at length
when we talked about changes
in free energy and how
that worked for pathways,
is that, remember, we discussed
that, if we start with wood
or oil and all in one
step burn it to CO2,
it releases a certain
amount of energy.
Or we can break that
into individual steps,
as we did in glycolysis.
The same amount of
energy is released.
But by breaking into
individual steps,
we can now capture that
energy as intermediates
such that we can, say,
favorably synthesize ATP
at a high ATP/ADP
ratio in cells.
The exact same thing is true
about any of these electron
transfers.
There is the change in
standard reduction potential.
Or the change in free energy
as one moves from electron
transfer from one
acceptor to one donor
is the same if
you go in one step
or in many different steps.
And so by doing these
stepwise electron transfers
in exactly the same way we
discussed about for glycolysis,
we can capture that energy
release in smaller packets.
And this is a way to basically
better harness this energy
release to do useful
things for cells.
Ultimately, you'll see
it's how you make ATP,
but it can do
other work as well,
generate heat, move
ions, et cetera.
And so this is really what
I want to discuss today.
But it's important to remember
these concepts when we think
through how these systems work.
And so we've now
spent several lectures
discussing the chemical
details of how we can oxidize.
First, we discussed
carbohydrates.
Then we discussed fatty acids.
And what we saw is that
many of the electrons that
are lost from the
carbon oxidation
are used to generate molecules
such as NADH or FADH2
and effectively charge up
a ratio, if you will, of
reduce oxidized cofactors.
And these molecules then donate
those electrons, ultimately,
to oxygen. And it's that,
how you couple those electron
transfers from these
carriers to oxygen,
ultimately is what
oxidative phosphorylation is
about as a way to allow cells
to convert this energy released
into a biologically useful form.
Now, effectively,
the way biology
does this is by using that
favorable electron transfer
to oxygen to charge a battery.
So really oxidative
phosphorylation, if you will,
is about a biological battery.
And it's really
the same concepts
that you may have
learned in other courses
about how chemical
batteries work.
And so let's just
think about that.
What is a battery?
Well, a battery is two different
solutions of ions usually
that is separated
into two compartments.
It has a unit of volts.
That's exactly
what the units are
for this change in standard
reduction potential is volts.
By using that voltage to run
a current between the two
compartments, you can do work.
And if you short circuit
a battery, of course,
you can get some heat.
And so how are
these really made?
Well, you basically just
need to get that voltage.
You need to have something that
insulates between those two
compartments.
And you can then
control electron flow
from one side of the
circuit to the other.
And it's exactly the same
issue that happens in biology,
except biology
needs some insulator
between two compartments.
How do we create different
compartments in cells?
Well, we create
them with membranes.
And so an important function
of membranes in cells,
other than things like
separating cellular contents
from the outside
world or breaking up
different organelles,
is that cells actually
require a membrane.
They're essential
for life because they
are what allows an insulation
between two aqueous
compartments in a way
that you can build
a biological battery that is
really central to how life uses
energy as a way to do work.
And so life creates a voltage,
which I'm going to call delta
psi, delta pH-- we'll come
back to that in a little bit--
to basically couple favorable
electron transfer from, say,
an electron carrier
like NAD/NADH to oxygen,
so reoxidizing NADH to
reduce oxygen to water.
That is moving from a lower
to a higher standard reduction
potential that's favorable.
Delta G0 prime is negative.
Net transfer is favorable.
This can be coupled to doing
some work that otherwise would
be unfavorable, in this
case pumping protons
from one side of the
membrane to another.
By pumping protons to one side
of a membrane or the other,
you create a voltage
membrane potential, often
abbreviated delta psi.
It's also a pH gradient,
so delta H. The protons
have lower pH on one side of
the membrane than the other.
And it's this charging of a
battery at a membrane that
is what is captured by oxidative
phosphorylation, what's
typically referred to as that
process, as a way to make ATP.
But of course, this
is a useful thing.
It's a battery.
And so it can also do
other work for cells.
Now, I just want
to say and really
stress that this is really
critical, this process.
And it's really central to
how energy works for cells.
You will see that,
effectively, this
is the key steps
in photosynthesis,
do exactly the same thing.
It's how mitochondria work.
It's also how bacteria work.
And really prokaryotes end
up doing this at their plasma
membranes, whereas mitochondria
and chloroplasts end up
doing this at intracellular
membranes in eukaryotes.
But ultimately,
it's the same idea
of charging this biological
battery that really allows
cells to convert, do
energy conversions
in a way that's useful for
them to allow otherwise
unfavorable things
to happen in cells.
Now, this works
largely because you
have this insulating
membrane system, which is,
of course, made of lipids.
Lipids are what separates
the two compartments.
Remember, we discussed earlier
that these lipid bilayers
are useful because they
create a hydrophobic interface
between two aqueous
compartments.
It's also useful
because lipids are
poor conductors of electrons.
And so this really ends up
being the insulating system
that makes this work.
Now, in the previous
lecture, we discussed
a lot about the polar
and non-polar properties
of phospholipids really
allow them to assemble
into these membrane barriers.
And I just want to
do a slight diversion
to revisit this in
the context of how
this works for bioenergetics.
So remember, you have
this lipid bilayer where
you separate two
aqueous compartments
with this hydrophobic membrane.
In this membrane are
these phospholipids,
where you have these polar head
groups with two lipid tails.
You can look back to a
former lecture where I drew
and we discussed what
those phospholipids
are in great detail.
But it's really having that
polar, non-polar interface
that allows you to form
these bilayers that's
creating this separation between
the aqueous compartments,
but also this insulator that
allows a battery to be built
across the membrane.
Now, there are several
consequences, though,
to this system that is worth
thinking about at least
in terms of how lipids
and membranes work.
Now, a consequence of
this is that, if we're
going to create
this system, now we
create a system where we
have issues with transport
across from one
compartment to another.
Now, this, of course,
is an opportunity
for a layer of regulation
because it also
allows then these
conditions where
you could have different
chemical conditions,
say, different ATP/ADP
ratios, NAD/NADH ratios
in the different compartments,
which, of course,
for all the thermodynamic
reasons we've already discussed
can make things more or
less favorable to occur
in different
compartments in cells.
But it also means
metabolism then
has to have ways to transport
stuff across these membranes.
And we've discussed
this a couple of times.
A few examples--
I talked briefly
about the pyruvate carrier.
That is, if glycolysis
is happening
in this compartment
in the cytosol
and we need to get the pyruvate
inside the mitochondria
across a membrane for the
pyruvate dehydrogenase
reaction, now you needed this
pyruvate carrier molecule.
And it turns out that
that transport process
is an opportunity
for regulation,
but it still needs to occur.
We discussed the
carnitine shuttle, right?
Fatty acid, we generate
fatty acyl-CoAs
from breakdown of
lipids in one side
in the cytosolic compartment.
We need to get those fatty
acyl-CoAs into the mitochondria
where they can be oxidized
by fatty acid oxidation.
And that required that
carnitine shuttle system.
Now, ultimately, what mediates
this transport is, of course,
proteins that can sit within
this membrane bilayer.
And you can imagine
you can have proteins
that span the
membrane bilayer, such
that there's hydrophilic
surfaces that
are on either face of the
membrane and hydrophobic
residues in the middle
with various ways
to make channels and other
transport mechanisms to get
things from one side of
the membrane to the other,
all right?
Or you could have complexes that
float freely within the lipid
bilayer, such that there's
a hydrophilic surface that
faces one compartment and a
hydrophobic surface that faces
the inside of the membrane.
Now, having these complexes
will become very important
for ways in which one can
regulate processes that
occur either within the
membrane or by moving things
across membranes, like
generating moving protons
and generating a
voltage, or even
move large things like
proteins across the membrane.
But it has additional
consequences because it now
means that the properties
of the membrane
also matter somewhat as well.
And this brings us back
to the other discussion
we had in the last lecture.
And that is how the various
properties of the fatty acids
that exist within this
hydrophobic membrane area also,
now, can really
matter because they're
going to affect things
about how leaky this
is as an insulator between
the two compartments,
as well as how fluid
the membrane is,
such that things
like these proteins
can actually move within
this hydrophobic barrier
between the two compartments.
In other words, the fatty
acid composition, as well as
the lipid species
themselves, that
is which phospholipid, other
polar hydrophobic lipid
species analogous to
phospholipids that form up
membranes, can change
properties such as how leaky
the membrane is or how
fluid the membrane is.
You can imagine, if you have a
really rigid membrane surface,
you're not going to get
any flow of materials.
It's not going to be very
leaky, which might be great
if you want to build an
insulator between the two
compartments.
But it's going to be very
difficult to regulate transport
across that compartment.
And so nature has come up with
a bunch of different solutions
for how to play with fatty acid
and other lipid composition
to change the
properties of membranes.
We don't have time to get
into that in great detail
in this course, but I
want you to appreciate
that these things exist.
But one thing I want to
discuss is that often,
when you see phospholipids
drawn like this,
they're drawn in this
way where the polar head
group is a circle.
And then they'll draw the
two lipids tails often
with a kink in one
of the lipid tails.
That's because many times
phospholipids, of the two lipid
tails, one is saturated.
And one has a
monounsaturation in it.
And I just want to go
back to the models here.
Remember, the monounsaturated,
the double bond,
ends up being this
cis double bond.
And so here's two fatty acids.
If you put these here in with
the head groups on one side--
so this would be esterified to
the glycerol, the phospholipid,
you end up getting this
kink in the membrane, which
is much different than
two straight chains.
You can imagine that
within the membrane
itself this ends up basically
not letting those lipid tails
pack quite so tightly in the
membrane, which certainly
contributes to an
ability to have space
to put other stuff in
the membrane to allow
other processes to happen.
Now, recall that
there's other ways
we can modulate the
properties of fatty acids,
introduce more double bonds,
chain length, et cetera.
And different organisms
use different strategies
to deal with this.
And so plants,
remember, have all kinds
of polyunsaturated fatty acids,
just like we talked about
with plant oils being
liquid at room temperature.
Having more polyunsaturated
fatty acids in their lipid
tails is one way
plants use to keep
their membranes more fluid.
Animals, remember, have
more saturated fatty acids.
All right, those
saturated fatty acids--
less double bonds, going
to be higher melting
temperature, more likely to
be solid at room temperature.
So that's not going to be very
good for membrane fluidity.
And it turns out animals
use a different strategy
to keep membrane
fluidity that's not
polyunsaturated fatty acids.
And that is that they
incorporate this molecule shown
here on the slide,
which is cholesterol,
which you're well aware of.
And so animals use you
sterols, like cholesterol,
as a way to keep their
membranes more fluid.
And so that cholesterol that
is present in animal products
is not there to give
you heart attacks.
It's really there
as a way animals use
to keep their membranes fluid.
And this is really,
at heart, why
plants are cholesterol
free foods and animals have
cholesterol.
And it's because animals
use cholesterol as a way
to keep their membranes
fluid, whereas plants
use a different strategy,
polyunsaturated fatty acids.
All right, now,
ultimately setting up
the system this way is
important because it allows
for these flexible
membranes that
can enable ion and other
transport between compartments,
as well as hold a charge so that
you can form this battery which
allows oxidative phosphorylation
or other processes to occur
where you can
charge this membrane
and ultimately use that
voltage to do work,
like make ATP, all right?
Now, how this membrane
charging occurs,
again, is really taking
advantage of favorable electron
transfer across a
series of redox pairs,
ultimately, to oxygen or
another good electron acceptor.
And it's really that
favorable electron transfer
that's being coupled to
this pumping of proton ions
to charge a battery.
That's the oxidation part.
And then that battery doing work
such as driving favorable ADP
to ATP conversion,
the phosphorylation
part of oxidative
phosphorylation,
is the type of work
that you can then
do once you generate this
chemical battery, although not
the only work you can
do with that battery.
And it's why this
is so much more
flexible than just making ATP.
All right, so
ultimately this process
by coupling transfer
of electrons
from favorable
oxidation of carbon
to charge up these other
electron carriers that
ultimately transfer to
oxygen is a major way
that life uses nutrient
oxidation to convert it
to biologically useful energy.
And this is where we get to this
process of what is typically
referred to as oxidative
phosphorylation, which
is a concept or a process that
was often abbreviated oxphos.
And it was discovered by or
first described by a gentleman
by the name of Peter Mitchell.
And like many novel or
revolutionary ideas,
when Peter Mitchell first
described or proposed
the processes I'm about
to tell you about,
his ideas were
initially dismissed.
It was thought at the time, when
people were thinking about how
do you couple metabolism to,
say, charge up your ATP/ADP
ratio, that that
process would work
via the oxidative
phosphorylation type reactions
that we otherwise
described, things
like what happens at the GAPDH
step or the succinic thiokinase
step in the TCA cycle.
Those are two examples
where we could directly
couple the oxidation of carbon
to a phosphorylation event that
ultimately allowed us
to favorably produce
ATP to maintain an
ATP/ADP ratio that's high
and is present in cells.
However, what Peter
Mitchell described
was really this
battery phenomena
that we're talking about.
And it turned out
to be largely right
and represents something
that's actually
quite unique about
biological processes
even if you think about other
biological processes that
occur.
And that is what he
proposed was the oxidation
and phosphorylation events were
actually separate processes.
That is nature does not have
to have these two things touch
in order for them to work.
That is that you use
oxidation to create
this battery as one event.
So oxidation generates this
potential across a membrane.
And then that potential
across a membrane
is a totally separate event,
can drive phosphorylation, ATP,
or do other work,
ultimately making
this a more flexible
system for biology.
And so turns out, as I said
before, in a prokaryotic cell--
so this here is some
kind of prokaryote, OK?
Prokaryotes have a membrane
that separates them
from the outside world.
This cell membrane effectively
couples that oxidation step
to the pumping of protons.
That creates a battery
at the cell membrane
of the prokaryote.
And separate in
space, that can then
be used to drive
ATP synthesis or do
other work that's useful to
maintain that prokaryotic cell.
Now, in eukaryotes, this
process occurs at membranes
within the mitochondria.
So this here is a
mitochondria, OK?
So just to remind you of some
very basic cell biology--
and so, remember, mitochondria
have two membranes.
So there's this outer
mitochondrial membrane,
outer mitochondrial membrane.
And then there's this inner
mitochondrial membrane,
so two membranes in
the mitochondria.
Remember, there's
this matrix space.
The cytosol would be out here.
And then there's this space
between the two membranes
called the intermembrane
space, intermembrane space
between the two membranes.
If you'll recall, many of these
oxidation reactions, the TCA
cycle, fatty acid oxidation,
pyruvate dehydrogenase step,
all of those were happening in
the matrix of the mitochondria.
Remember, glycolysis
was in the cytosol,
but all these other
processes were
happening in the matrix
of the mitochondria.
And really what's going
on is that this battery is
being charged across this inner
mitochondrial membrane, OK?
So protons are being pumped
into the inner mitochondrial
membrane into the intermembrane
space of the mitochondria
and then used to synthesize
ATP in the matrix
of the mitochondria.
Now, part of this came,
many people know-- remember,
mitochondria have their
own DNA, et cetera.
And so really where
people thought,
think eukaryotic cells
came from is basically
the mitochondria is an enslaved
bacteria or an obligate
captured symbiont, if you
will, where one cell engulfed
a different prokaryotic cell.
And if you track this, think
of the inner mitochondrial
membrane as a enslaved
prokaryotic cell,
you can see that
you're generating
this membrane potential
across the inner mitochondrial
membrane, which is
really equivalent
to the bacterial membrane of
the enslaved prokaryotic cell.
In both cases, it's
creating this battery
at a membrane, the inner
mitochondrial membrane
or the bacterial membrane of
a prokaryote, that is then
being used to
separately in space
use that gradient to do
work, such as synthesize ATP.
So if I draw this more
explicitly as this here
being the membrane--
so the inner
mitochondrial membrane
of a mitochondria or
the bacterial membrane
of a prokaryotic
cell, such that this
is outside the bacteria,
that's inside the bacteria.
This is the intermembrane
space often referred to
as the cytosol side.
Of course, there's another outer
mitochondrial membrane here
that, for the sake
of this class,
you can just think of as
being generally permeable.
This would be the matrix inside
of the inner mitochondrial
membrane.
And so all this NADH
is being generated
from nutrient
oxidation TCA cycle,
fatty acid oxidation,
pyruvate dehydrogenase,
whatever, within the matrix
or within the bacteria.
Those electrons are ultimately
being transferred from NADH,
reoxidizing it to NAD, to
reduce oxygen to water.
This is favorable.
This is, therefore,
coupled to pumping protons.
That creates a membrane
potential and gradient
across this membrane,
which can be
used to do work such as
driving the synthesis of ATP
for other work.
So this all has to happen
at the same membrane,
but this process does not
have to touch that process.
It's coupled because
you create this battery,
this membrane potential
and pH gradient, that
can be used elsewhere
along the membrane
to do some kind of work.
Now, I draw this is
delta psi, delta pH.
You can imagine, if
you're moving protons,
you're going to
create a voltage.
You're also going to
create a pH gradient.
It turns out I don't
have time to discuss
this further in the class.
A lot is written
about how to think
about this membrane potential
as either a true voltage
or as a pH gradient.
It turns out that
they're useful to think
about in different ways
for different processes.
But if you're
interested in this,
there's certainly lots written
about this on various papers
and texts on bioenergetics.
And I would encourage you
to read more about that.
OK.
All right, what
I want to do next
then is discuss each
of these processes
in turn, that is
how does this work
and how does that work,
to really understand
what's going on in
mitochondria and bacteria
to carry out this process of
oxidative phosphorylation.
So first, let's talk here.
First, how does one use
favorable electron transfer
to make this membrane potential?
Obviously, if we're
going to pump protons
against a gradient, such that
we have different concentration
of protons on either
side of the membrane,
that's going to
require energy input.
And that energy is going to
come from favorable electron
transfer.
And really this process is
taking electrons from, say,
a cofactor like NADH, and
ultimately transferring
those electrons to
oxygen to get water.
The standard reduction
potential of NAD/NADH
is less than the
standard reduction
potential of oxygen and water.
That means that equilibrium
is going to favor electron
transport in this direction.
To say it another way,
relative to oxygen-water,
NAD/NADH is a better
electron donor.
Oxygen-water is a better
electron acceptor pair.
And so by this electron
transfer being favorable,
it can be used then
to release energy
coupled to other processes,
such as moving protons
and make that otherwise
unfavorable process favorable.
Now, you'll note
that, in doing this,
we now regenerate the
oxidized cofactor NAD+.
And so that solves our electron
balance problem for glycolysis,
solves any electron
balance problem
that would exist for fatty
acid oxidation or the TCA cycle
in the mitochondria.
Because ultimately,
those electrons
are being given to
oxygen. And so oxygen,
being this final
electron acceptor,
being stoichiometrically
produced to generate water,
is effectively water being
the alternative waste product
to, say, lactate
or ethanol that we
saw in fermentation, all right?
Now, as we started the
lecture with and discussed
in glycolysis, if we do this
in one step, it's favorable.
But it's also favorable if we
do it in lots of little steps.
By doing it and lots
of little steps,
just like we did
in glycolysis, we
can break up that
energy release in a way
to allow us to do
more work, right?
So in glycolysis, we could
turn carbohydrate into CO2--
one step, burning wood,
release a lot of light and heat
all in one step.
That can be used to do work.
But it was more efficient to
break it up into little steps
where we could then
capture intermediates
that made ATP synthase favorable
despite high ATP/ADP ratio.
Same idea here, we could
transfer this all in one step.
But instead, you break
it up into a bunch
of individual steps, which can
then be coupled individually
to pumping protons
across the membrane
to generate more efficiently
this delta PSI delta pH
to charge this battery.
And so this occurs across a
series of electron carriers,
multi-protein complexes,
electron carriers,
called the electron
transport chain.
And you can think of this
electron transport chain
as being entirely analogous
to what we already
talked about when
we talked about how
pyruvate dehydrogenase
or alpha-ketoglutarate
dehydrogenase works when we
talked about the TCA cycle.
Remember, these had these
different protein complexes,
this E1, E2, E3,
where electrons were
transferred across this chain.
It's exactly the same
idea here, a number
of multi-polypeptide
encoded protein complexes
that come together to hold
a bunch of electron carriers
that break up the energy
release, if you will,
as we oxidize NADH and
reduce oxygen and transfer
those electrons along the chain
with the complexes themselves
coupling the favorable
electron transfer to the moving
of protons against a gradient
across the membrane to work.
And so for this electron
transport chain to work,
we obviously need a bunch
of electron carriers.
And why you need more
than one electron carrier
should now be obvious.
Because having
different carriers that
sit at different
standard reduction
potentials is going
to be useful if we
want to build a chain such that
we can have favorable oxidation
and reduction to move electrons
in a favorable direction
and couple that to
processes that allow
us to charge this battery.
And so it turns out that
for this electron transport
chain to work--
well, we know about some
of our electron carriers.
So we've discussed NAD, NADH.
There's FAD, FADH2.
There was lipoic acid.
Lipoic acid is not part of
the electron transport chain.
NAD, NADH is a donor.
You'll see FAD can be part of
the electron transport chain,
but there's a different--
or there's additional
electron carriers.
I want to discuss those now.
So another important
one is something called
FMN or Flavin Mononucleotide.
What FMN, or Flavin
Mononucleotide is, is it's
effectively FAD.
But it's a FAD not in
a dinucleotide state,
but a mononucleotide state.
So if you take FAD and you
remove an AMP group from it,
what you're left with is FMN.
So just to remind you to
be explicit about this--
so.
So you have this flavin group
attached to this ribitol group
with a phosphate on it.
If I put another phosphate and
an adenine nucleotide here,
an AMP group attached
here, that would be FAD.
This would be FMN, nucleotide
instead of a dinucleotide.
This is FMN in
the oxidized form.
And just like FAD, it can
accept an electron pair.
So here's our hydride
ion, two electrons
if we just draw here the
middle part of the molecule.
And so this here would be
FMNH2 or the reduced form
of this electron carrier, OK?
So flavin mononucleotide--
part of the electron transport
chain.
Now, note FMN, FAD,
NAD, all of these things
are two electron
carriers, right?
We disguise the
mechanism of all of them,
just reminded you of
it, these hydride ion
transfers, two
electron carriers.
It turns out the electron
transport chain also
uses metal ions as
electron carriers.
And so-- lots of minerals in
our diet, things like iron.
It turns out elemental iron
is a great electron carrier.
And it's very important for
electron transport chain.
Now, elemental metals
are one electron carrier.
And so there's a few ways
you incorporate iron.
One is something called
iron sulfur clusters.
And so iron sulfur clusters
is, within a protein,
you have some cysteine residues.
And those cysteine residues
can coordinate an iron atom.
And so that iron atom can sit
in the 3+ versus 2+ state,
oxidized, reduced.
So reduction of the iron--
oxidation of the iron, OK?
So one electron carrier--
move one electron that way.
Also, ion sits within
molecules called cytochromes.
So what are cytochromes?
This is an iron atom
that's basically
chelated into a porphyrin
very similar to what
you saw for hemoglobin.
And so you have an iron 2+ or 3+
that's chelated here into this
porphyrin ring structure.
OK.
Lots of conjugated double
bond systems in it,
this should look very similar.
Porphyrin is the thing on
the outside, coordinates iron
atom in the middle.
That can move between the 2+
and the 3+ state just like we do
for iron sulfur clusters, so
carry electrons be oxidized
or reduced, 3+ or 2+.
And ultimately,
this porphyrin can
have some R groups added here,
can be associated with it
or bound to cysteine
residues within proteins.
Effectively, these molecules
varying these R groups
and how it's
attached to proteins
gives you different families
of cytochrome is referred
to as cytochrome A, the B type
cytochromes, and cytochrome C.
These are associated
with enzyme complexes,
cytochrome C. It's
actually covalently bound
to the polypeptide itself.
Basically, these are
named because you
have these different conjugated
ring structures here.
That and how the R groups
are will slightly change.
So this will absorb
visible light.
That will slightly change
the absorption spectra.
And so classically, based
on absorption spectra,
these were classified into
A, B, and C type cytochromes.
And you can imagine,
by these properties
having slightly different--
affecting the iron in
ways that it slightly
affects its electron
transport properties.
Of course, hemoglobin
almost certainly
evolved from these molecules
as oxygen carrying ways
in multicellular life.
But of course, the original
use was as electron carriers
for the processes
here that we're
going to talk about, to
hold that iron as a way
to control electron transport
across these electron transport
chains.
All right, so that's iron.
It turns out iron is
not the only metal that
can be used to do this.
And so cells also use copper.
And so histidine can coordinate
a copper that can move between
an oxidized and reduced state,
so copper 2+ reduced to copper
+, copper + to copper 2+ or
copper + oxidized to copper 2+,
another one electron carrier.
And so iron and copper can
act as one electron carriers.
And so you have these
two electron carriers.
Here's a bunch of metals
as one electron carriers.
Obviously, you need ways
to carry both one and two
electrons if you're
going to move
electrons between these
different carriers.
And an important molecule
to do that is something
called coenzyme Q. Coenzyme Q--
sometimes referred to
as ubiquinone ubiquinol,
because it's ubiquitous, often
abbreviated co-Q. Many of you
have probably heard
of the supplement
CoQ10, very popular
supplement out there.
CoQ10 is basically a
version of coenzyme Q,
ubiquinone, ubiquinol.
What this looks
like is as follows.
So this here is ubiquinone,
the oxidized form.
So this middle part
is the quinone.
And then you have these
decorations on the outside,
including this R group.
This R group is typically
a long acyl tail.
If it's 10 carbons long,
that's CoQ10 supplement.
Having this long
acyl chain makes this
a very hydrophobic molecule.
And it actually lives
within the membrane itself
as an electron carrier.
And so this ubiquinone can
pick up an electron as well as
a proton.
Whoops.
And so by picking
up one electron,
it can then basically go here
to this semiquinone stabilized
free radical state
and then pick up
a second electron to go
to the fully reduced form.
ubiquinol.
OK.
So one electronic carrier
and two electron carrier--
so basically, it can
carry two electrons
from the oxidized,
the reduced form,
but can transfer them
as single electrons
by going through this stabilized
free radical ubiquinone state.
And so, basically, these
various electron carriers
are associated with
these protein complexes
within this electron transport
chain that ultimately works
to couple favorable
electron transport down
the chain to pumping protons
to generate this potential
across the membrane.
All right, so this
process occurs, again,
at the bacterial membrane or
the inner mitochondrial membrane
and, in animals
and most organisms,
operates with four large
multi-subunit protein
complexes, all right?
Each of these protein complexes
has multiple polypeptides,
as I said.
It's coming together to form
these complexes just like we
described for pH, for instance.
Most of the
components of this are
encoded in the nuclear
genome, but a subset of these
are encoded in the
mitochondrial genome.
Now, what exactly is encoded in
different mitochondrial genomes
varies by organisms.
But across organisms,
it's basically
mostly complex components
of these protein complexes.
And so this is why
mitochondrial DNA is retained.
It's kind of this vestige of
this symbiotic relationship.
The mitochondria have
retained some of the ability
to control their own
energy transduction, sort
of core components
of these complexes.
There is one soluble protein.
So these complexes are
embedded within the membrane.
There's also one
soluble protein that's
associated with the membrane.
And then there's
coenzyme Q, which also
floats within the membrane.
So that's in the membrane.
These are embedded
in the membrane.
And then there's a
soluble protein that's
associated with the membrane.
OK, now I want to discuss the
details of what these protein
complexes are and also few
comments about how they work.
So if this is the
inner membrane space
and this is the
matrix side, that'd
be out or in if we're
discussing a prokaryote.
The first is we have something
called complex I, also
referred to as NADH oxidase
because it oxidizes NADH back
to NAD.
NADH oxidase is a giant complex
greater than 900 kilodaltons
in total.
It has more than 25
individual protein subunits,
contains some flavin
mononucleotides as well as
some iron sulfur clusters
as electron carriers.
And it is the least
well-understood
of all of the protein complexes.
In fact, it is still
a major field of study
to try to understand how
NAD oxidase really works.
But it effectively is one of the
complexes that can pump protons
across the membrane as those
two electrons are transferred
through the complex from NADH
ultimately to coenzyme Q that
exists within the membrane.
OK, the next complex
discuss is complex II.
Complex II is succinate
dehydrogenase, the exact enzyme
that we heard about
from the TCA cycle.
So what does succinate
dehydrogenase do?
Remember, it converts
fumarate to succinate.
It gave those electrons
to FAD to make FADH2.
Well, that occurs
within this complex,
which can also reoxidize the
FADH2 with those two electrons
and give them,
also, to coenzyme Q
that sits within the membrane.
So I want to point out that
this, ultimately, you will see,
is why it is that electron
transfer from NADH and FADH2
has different energy yields.
And so the electron transfer
from NADH to ubiquinone
is more of a change in
standard reduction potential
than from FADH2 to ubiquinone.
Why use FADH2?
Well, because, remember when
we did electron transfers,
we used, when we
oxidized a carbon, say,
in a carbohydrate to a ketone,
we tended to use NAD+/NADH
as the electron transport pair.
So this change in
standard reduction
potential is such that we
can make that reaction work
and ultimately drive that.
It turns out that putting
a double bond in--
this going from a not oxidizing
an alcohol to a ketone,
but oxidizing the carbon
to a double bond--
that basically you
need a different change
in standard reduction potential
to carry out that reaction
and make it work.
FADH/FADH2 sits at a
higher standard reduction
potential than NAD/NADH.
And so that means to
further transfer them
to something further
downstream, like coenzyme Q,
there's a bigger change in
standard reduction potential
here.
That can be used
to drive protons.
There's not enough
of a change here.
You can't use that
to drive protons.
And it's because of
these differences
in what's actually being
oxidized that ultimately leads
to this difference in energetics
when we think about FADH2
versus NADH and how
much ATP equivalence
that they might have for cells.
All right, once electrons
are in the ubiquinone pool
or coenzyme Q pool, they can now
be transferred to complex III.
So complex III is also referred
to as cytochrome C reductase.
You'll see why in a second.
It's a 250 kilodalton complex.
There are 10 subunits.
It has a bunch of B type
and C type cytochromes,
as well as some iron
sulfur clusters.
Shown here on the
slide from a textbook
is a picture of complex III and
what it actually looks like.
Fairly well-understood
how it works,
this coupling of basically
electron transfer through the Q
pool can pump protons.
And this ultimately
allows transfer
of electrons to this
small soluble protein that
lives in the intermembrane space
or associated with the outside
of the bacteria
called cytochrome C--
or outside in the intermembrane
space called cytochrome C.
Cytochrome C is a 13
kilodalton protein.
It's a very small
highly conserved protein
with a C type
cytochrome commonly used
because it's found across
many, many different types
of organisms.
And so it's been sequenced
from many, many organisms
as a way to identify
evolutionary relationships.
And then cytochrome
C, this is also
why it's called cytochrome
C reductase because it's
reducing cytochrome C
to transfer electrons
along the chain, ultimately to
the final complex, complex IV.
Complex IV-- also referred
to as cytochrome C oxidase.
And this is ultimately the place
where electrons are transferred
to reduce oxygen to water.
So this is 160 kilodalton
protein complex
with 13 subunits, uses A
type cytochromes and copper
as electron carriers
and, ultimately,
allows you to get electrons
from cytochrome C to oxygen.
And so here, again,
from the textbook
is a picture of complex
IV and what it looks like.
Also, fairly well-understood--
also couples electron transport
to proton pumping.
And so this is effectively
the electron transport chain
as it exists in mitochondria.
And you can draw it a different
way as I will do here.
So here's complex I, allows
oxidation of NADH back to NAD+.
That oxidation can be
coupled to reduction of FMN.
Ultimately, those are passed
through some iron sulfur
clusters leading to the
reduction of ubiquinone.
And in the process,
this electron transport
can pump on the order
of four protons,
or at least that's
what's estimated.
Complex II, which is succinate
dehydrogenase from the TCA
cycle, really converts
succinate to fumarate.
That oxidation reaction
within the complex
leads to the reduction
of FAD to FADH2.
That can be reoxidized
through iron,
ultimately driving the
reduction of coenzyme Q
from ubiquinone to ubiquinol.
That ubiquinone to you
ubiquinol in something
called the Q pool
within the membrane
can then be reoxidized
in complex III.
That reoxidized in
complex III puts electrons
through complex III that
can be coupled to pumping
on the order of two protons.
Those electrons are transferred
to cytochrome C. Ultimately,
those electrons are transferred
to copper in complex IV
to cytochrome A and,
ultimately, oxygen to water,
reducing oxygen to
water and pumping
on the order of four protons.
And so you can see here
that, basically, this
is a series of oxidation
and reduction reactions
that happens across these
complexes, such that complex I,
the transfer electrons from
the Q pool through complex III.
And complex IV can pump
protons across the membrane
and generate this
delta psi delta
pH that can be used to do work.
And it's really the favorable
transfer of electrons
either from NAD/NADH or the
oxidation of the succinate
to fumarate with those electrons
being given to oxygen to drive
this process.
And so really just to schematize
this, in a way, is that,
if this is our membrane, NAD+ to
NADH gives electrons to complex
I, which goes to coenzyme Q,
which goes to complex III,
which goes to cytochrome
C, which goes to complex IV
and reduces oxygen to water.
That is one way to carry
out this set of reactions.
The other way is we
can convert fumarate--
sorry, succinate to fumarate.
That's the FAD.
That's complex II, also
gives it to the Q pool.
And so you can see that
the electron transport
chain would be complex I, Q,
III C, IV or II Q, III, C IV.
It is not I, II, III, IV.
It is actually I to Q or II
to Q, ultimately going to III.
Now, the way protons
are pumped is a process
that I don't have time this
year to discuss in class.
I will post something
on Stellar that is just
a short section from the
textbook that describes
at least what is known about
how that process works,
such as the Q cycle,
basically how oxidation
and reduction of coenzyme
Q, which will take protons
on and off the molecule on
either side of the membrane,
can be used to show how this
can be coupled to proton
pumping across the membrane.
And you can read that
if you're interested.
OK.
Now, a couple other
points about this, this
works because you're
moving from a lower
to a higher standard reduction
potential across the chain.
And it turns out oxygen is
a particularly good electron
acceptor.
And this is really why oxygen
and respiration is really
so vital to a lot of the
way energy transduction
works in metabolism.
Oxygen is now abundant.
And being a great electron
acceptor is why it's used.
But of course, oxygen
was not abundant
2 and 1/2 billion years ago.
And it doesn't have to be
oxygen for this to work.
If you have another
electron acceptor that
basically makes this
process favorable,
that can work just as well.
And in fact, that happens
still in some very extreme
environments.
This so-called
chemosynthesis basically
can use other
electronic acceptors
to drive the
energetics of cells.
And you really just
need the right ways
to build an electron transport
chain to make this whole system
work, such you can build a
battery and use it to do work,
OK?
So oxygen-- commonly used
because it's abundant and good
at it, but it's not the
only way that this can work.
And there are
examples in biology
where oxygen is not used, that
there is other acceptors that
are used instead.
Now, I also want to note, as
I've alluded to in discussing
complex II, this FAD/FADH2.
So when we talk about
that in the TCA cycle
or in fatty acid
oxidation, we discuss it
as if it's kind of like
NAD/NADH, but it's not.
NAD/NADH are basically
cofactors that
move around between enzymes.
Fad/fadh2 are not free.
They're electron carriers that
are part of protein complexes,
like what we described up here.
And they're part of enzymes
like succinate dehydrogenase.
So complex II just happens to be
an FAD/FADH2 containing enzyme
that's part of the TCA cycle and
part of the electron transport
chain as a way to transfer
electrons in the TCA cycle
into the Q pool
via this succinate
to fumarate conversion.
Acyl-CoA dehydrogenase,
the FAD/FADH2 enzyme
we discussed in
fatty acid oxidation,
could easily be drawn instead
in electron transport chain that
goes acyl-CoA dehydrogenase,
coenzyme Q, III, C, IV,
just like we can say
succinate to fumarate
is the same as complex
II, Q, III, C, IV, OK?
And so there's really lots of
alternative electron transport
chains that involve these
FAD/FADH2 containing enzymes
that really sit in the membrane
and directly transfer electrons
to the Q pool.
Ultimately, the
goal of all of this
is, of course, to create
this delta psi delta
pH, which can be used to charge
this battery that then can then
be done to do work.
And so this work includes
the phosphorylation of ATP.
And so if we charge
this battery,
we can now use this as a way to
couple current in this battery
to phosphorylate ADP to make
ATP, the phosphorylation part
of oxidative phosphorylation.
Now, this occurs also by a
large protein complex sometimes
referred to as complex
V. But remember,
complex V, or this ATP
synthase machinery,
is not really part of the
electron transport chain.
It is separate in space and
is basically something, a way,
to utilize this delta psi
delta pH across the membrane
to drive ATP synthesis.
All right, how does this
complex V or ATP synthesis work?
So this is also a
large protein complex,
sits within the same
membrane, of course,
because it has to utilize the
membrane potential to function.
And the so-called
complex V is also
referred to as the ATP
synthase or the F0 F1 ATPase.
And basically, if this is
the intermembrane space,
this is the inner
mitochondrial membrane.
This is the matrix.
You have a protein
complex that sits
within the membrane called F0.
It's actually FO.
The O stands for a
Oligomycin because there's
a drug called oligomycin
that inhibits the FO,
or F0, part of the molecule.
And then there's
this F1 component
that is associated with
the F0 component that
sits on the matrix
side of the membrane.
And it is effectively
the machine
that phosphorylates
or interconverts
ATP and ADP on the matrix
side of the membrane.
Now, it's pretty well-understood
how this system works.
And basically, F1
works by a process
called rotational catalysis.
How this works was awarded
the Nobel Prize in 1997,
figured out not
all that long ago.
And basically, this is F1 is
a large protein complex where
you have a gamma
subunit that is attached
to F0 the couples, basically,
proton pumping to this gamma
subunit to literally
turn the F1 component
and change the confirmation
of attached regions, parts,
of this F1 machine.
Because it turns
out you can have
three different conformations
of the rest of F1,
the so-called L, or Loose,
conformation, the T,
or Tight, conformation, or
the O, or Open, conformation.
And so in the open conformation,
ADP and phosphate or ATP
can exchange in and out of
this complex, all right?
In the loose confirmation,
you basically
have ADP and phosphate bound.
And in the tight
conformation, this
is favored to synthesize ATP.
And so you can envision that
what actually happens here
is that you first
have ADP and ATP
bind in this open conformation.
Protons are moved.
You get rotation around
the gamma subunit.
That changes the
conformation of the O subunit
to the loose subunit.
So now, you have
ADP plus PI bound.
Another proton moves,
changes the conformation
of the loose subunit into
the tight confirmation.
Now, ATP synthase is favored.
Another proton moves, comes
back to the open conformation.
ATP is released
from the molecule,
and you can run another
rotational catalysis cycle
again to ultimately drive
ATP to ATP synthase using
this transfer of protons
across the F0 subunit
to ultimately rotate this
machine to synthesize ATP.
Now, the way F0 works
is within the membrane--
and this is always
hard to draw--
you basically have
a central complex
with another set of
complexes around it
that, within that, have
two half-channels that
are open to either
side of the membrane.
And so if you look at
this from the top view,
so looking at it
straight down, you'd
have this central piece
with this external piece
with the two half-channels that
basically can rotate around
the central stalk.
This is hooked up to
the gamma subunit of F1
in which drives
rotational catalysis.
And how this works
is that attached
to this inner piece that is
open to the half-channels
is an aspartate residue.
So this is an aspartic
acid residue that's there.
And recall that aspartic
acid, it's an acid.
So it can pick up a
proton or release a proton
from its acid group
depending on the pH
on either side of the membrane.
And so, remember,
there's a different pH
on the two sides
of the membrane.
And it's really that
difference in pH
that will allow favorable
turning around this center
stalk.
And so the pH in the
intermembrane space is lower.
So that means you're
more likely to favor
protonation of the aspartate.
It can then rotate, such as the
channel, that aspartate, is now
exposed to the other
channel, to the matrix side.
There, the pH is higher,
so favors deprotonation.
And basically, this will
drive motion of this piece
around the central stalk.
That being coupled to
the gamma subunit of F1
will cause the rotation
of the F1 subunit changing
the attached conformation of
the rest of the complex to favor
ATP synthesis.
And it's really this is
how moving of protons back
from the intermembrane
space to the matrix
can drive the synthesis of
ATP, the phosphorylation
part of this process.
And so now you
have a full picture
of how carbon oxidation really
releases energy in a way that's
coupled to do work in biology.
So we can, of course,
couple this directly,
as we did at GAPDH or
succinic thiokinase.
But mostly, it's captured to
charge up these NAD/NADH ratios
where favorable
electron transport can
be used to make this delta psi
delta pH in a membrane that
can be used also to synthesize
ATP despite a high ATP/ADP
ratio because that battery can
be used to drive this machine.
Now, I want to point out
that the ATP synthase is just
like any other enzyme
in any pathway.
And that is, if
conditions are right,
there's no reason
that this machine
has to drive ATP synthesis.
It could also
consume ATP as a way
to create a proton gradient.
That is use ATP
hydrolysis to pump
protons in the
opposite direction
into the intermembrane space.
Well, why would
you ever do that?
Well, you would do that
because having this battery
is useful because ATP is
not the only way that cells
can use energy to do work.
It turns out that having
a membrane potential
is useful for other things.
So if you're in
course nine, you know
that action potentials are
carried, basically electricity
along cells.
What is that?
That is basically changing
membrane potentials
across cells.
More generally,
membrane potentials
can be used to do lots
of other types of work.
And so ATP is only one way that
cells can use biological energy
because it can be
coupled to otherwise
unfavorable reactions.
But you can also
couple ion gradients
to unfavorable reactions
and use that to do work--
and so lots of useful
ways that delta psi delta
pH can be used by cells.
And so what are some of these?
Well, the first one is this
can be used to generate heat.
So if you're checking
your phone right now,
your phone is obviously
a very useful device
to do all kinds of work for you.
You can read whatever
you want on your phone,
use it to call people.
Well, what happens
if you short circuit
the battery in your phone?
Well, it'll get really hot.
And the same thing happens here.
Rather than use this delta
psi delta pH to generate ATP,
if I just put a hole
in the membrane,
something referred to as
an uncoupling protein, UCP,
Uncoupling Protein, this will
just allow the leak of protons
back across the membrane.
Well, that's short
circuiting the battery.
Energy has to be
dissipated somewhere,
and it's dissipated as heat.
And this is effectively ways in
which biology can create heat.
And so uncoupling proteins are
expressed in a tissue called
brown fat in mammals.
Brown fat is a way
to generate heat.
And it's one way that we
maintain our body temperatures.
Now, the system is imperfect.
And lots of cells,
all metabolism,
generates some heat.
If you've ever done
composting, you
know your compost pile gets hot.
That's because the
organisms there
that are metabolized in the
material in the compost pile
are generating some heat.
And that's because
membranes aren't perfect.
They're somewhat leaky.
Now, as humans, we work hard
to maintain a constant body
temperature.
And there's actually a
huge amount of energy
that goes into just maintaining
our body temperature.
But you can imagine
how efficiently
we couple these processes will
determine how many calories we
need to maintain heat.
And that's actually a
theory of weight control,
that those of us
out there who have
less well-coupled
mitochondria can
eat more because they waste
more energy in generating
heat than those of us who are
really efficient in doing this.
And in fact, there's
drugs that allow
you to uncouple
electron transport
generation of delta psi
delta pH from utilizing
that membrane potential.
And these are great
weight loss drugs.
Dinitrophenol was used middle
part of the last century
as a weight loss agent.
It was very effective.
The problem is it's also
incredibly dangerous
because people will die.
Because it turns out, if
you uncouple this process
and you don't have enough
ATP, you die really fast.
And so don't use that
drug, but it illustrates
how you can use this
battery to generate
heat, another form of energy.
Another big one is
membrane transport.
So if I want to concentrate
something-- and this
could be moving proteins.
Or it could be
moving other ions,
like in an action potential.
Those are unfavorable
processes, right?
I'm causing dissociation
of ions across membranes
or moving protein from one
side of a membrane to another.
One can couple those transfer
processes to these delta psi
delta pH as well.
And in fact, protein
import in the mitochondria
depends very much on
a membrane potential
to get those proteins in.
The mitochondria is
an important site
of calcium storage for cells.
Calcium is concentrated
in the mitochondria.
And that concentration
can be driven
by this membrane potential.
And of course, this
potential can also
use to power lots of shuttles,
like the carnitine shuttle,
and actually create
situations where
you have different conditions
across membranes as a way
to favor different chemistries.
And so the last thing
I want to mention
is, in fact, these
shuttles, which is just ways
that one can couple
membrane potential to drive
other things, can also be
really important for how
metabolism works.
And I just want to illustrate
one aspect of this.
So if I draw here
my mitochondria--
let me draw it up here.
If I draw a
mitochondria, so here's
all these processes
are happening here
where we have electron
transport generating
a potential across the
intermitochondrial membrane
that can be used
to synthesize ATP.
Well, this synthesis is
occurring in the mitochondria.
But ultimately, I need
to get that ATP out
into the cytosol for it
to be useful for the cell
to run otherwise unfavorable
processes in the cytosol.
And so one needs a
transporter for this.
There's some transporter
called the adenine nucleotide
transporter.
And this partially takes
advantage of the fact
that there's a charge
difference between ATP and ADP
to actually couple membrane
potential to exchange
of ATP/ADP between the cytosol
and the mitochondrial matrix.
Now, there's other issues we'll
talk about next time as well.
And so, remember,
some metabolism
is happening in the cytosol.
So glycolysis turning
glucose into pyruvate
is occurring in the cytosol.
We've already discussed.
That means you got
to get pyruvate
in the mitochondria
for the PDH reaction,
but this is also generating
NADH in the cytosol.
And if that NADH needs
to transfer its electrons
to oxygen, we also
have to get that
NADH into the mitochondrial
matrix or, more correctly,
transfer those electrons into
the mitochondrial matrix.
It turns out cells maintain
distinct NAD/NADH pools
in the mitochondria
and the cytosol.
That's part of the
conditions that
make different reactions
favorable in each compartment.
And how cells do that,
transfer those electrons
into the mitochondria, ends up
being another important thing
that has to be transport that's
driven across these membranes
where one can use
delta psi delta pH.
And we'll talk about that at
the start of the next lecture.
Thanks.